une véritable course contre la montre
pour sauver des vies tous ces décombres
plusieurs habitants sont toujours
coincés dimanche dernier un missile
russe ouragans a détruit le bâtiment à
châssis viard dans la région de donetsk
une attaque condamnée par le président
ukrainien
tous ceux qui ordonnent de telles
frappes tout ce qui vise nos villes les
zones résidentielles tu de manière
totalement délibéré nord pour sûr dont
le souffle de l'explosion a aussi
détruit une partie d'un immeuble voisin
mais les habitants ont réussi à
s'échapper
monfils qui a 32 ans est allé voir où se
trouvait le missile
lorsque le deuxième tir a eu lieu il a
sauté dans les couloirs et lui et son
père ont été assommés
il a pris son père sur ses épaules et
l'a traîné à travers les décombres pour
le traîner jusqu'aux scooter
la ville de châssis vieillard se trouve
non loin de cramât torse qu'eidos
l'audience que deux cibles de l'armée
russe moscou qui a annoncé début juillet
avoir pris le contrôle de la région de
lougansk disent maintenant salle de
donetsk pour occuper l'ensemble du
donbass
et depuis